التوجيه والدعوات لانقر بعدم التصعيد
والمطالبه القوات السوريه بتعزيز تواجدها
شمالا روسيا التي تلعب دور الوسيط قررت
ارسال التعزيزات العسكريه الى محافظه حلب
اثر مناشده قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لصد اي
هجوم بري تركي ضد المقاتلين الاكراده
فوضعت موسكو حجزا يفصل بين مناطق سيطره
القوات الكرديه وتلك الخاضعه للفصائل
السوريه المواليه لانقره كما ارسلت المزيد
من جنودها الى محيط مدينه كوباني الحدوديه
بالاضافه الى تعزيز زواجها في مطار
العسكري المجاور وفقا المرصد السوري قد
يكون الهدف من تلك التعزيزات وقفوا او
تاخير العمليات التركيه في مناطق سيطره
الاكراد القريبه من الحدود مع تركيا
مدعومه من ايران وقوات النظام السوري منذ
عام 2019 تم الاتفاق على انتشار القوات
الروسيه في المنطقه لصد هجوم بري تركي بعد
ثلاث هجمات ضد المقاتلين الاكراده هجمات
سمحت بدخول الفصائل السوريه المواليه
لانقر الى هذه المناطق الحدوديه ومنذ ذلك
الحين تهدد انقر بالسيطره على المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه وتقف لها موسكو بالمرصاد
[موسيقى]